who are the major players in this drug
war so the politicians the military the
police force the cartels all Mexican
then the United States
China just to lay out all the pieces on
the board first off there are giant
local drug markets in Mexico that are
fought over you know just local drug
markets that are huge in scope so no
exporting to other locations just to
start yeah yeah so
um a big a big problem in Mexico is
basically those local drug markets and
an example of that and when I have a lot
of experience with is the one in Tijuana
which not only feeds the local populace
but also feeds the populace from San
Diego that crosses down into into
Tijuana and buys their product there
um and now you know phenomenon that's
occurring now is uh marijuana
trafficking is going from California
down into Mexico because they produce
better wheat you know which is
fascinating to see now so there's
already a channel and you kind of like
reusing that channel yeah there's a lot
of people and vehicles getting checked
when they drive down in Tijuana is being
called San Diego South now because you
know all the economic migrants you know
uh uh living down there 90 percent of
all houses in in Tijuana new houses are
being bought up by Americans so that'll
tell you something about the impact and
change that's going on down there
so you have these local drug markets
that are being fought over
you also have these drug routes that go
through Mexico up into Mexico around
Mexico through the ocean and under the
wall you know drug tunnels over the wall
and on backpacks
on migrants that go up into the United
States
not only do the cartels make money off
uh drug trafficking but also extortion
money laundering paid protection schemes
you know any mining operation in Mexico
will have to pay protection you know or
else it'll get hit
uh a lot of times money the largest
money makers for some of these criminal
groups are you know um protecting and
taxing anybody that goes across the
border so that's also a big issue uh and
it's not just again uh some Americans
think it's like the cartels you know
they imagine this single or maybe two or
three groups there's there's several out
there
uh I don't have a current estimate but
last time I checked it was somewhere
where in the vicinity of 50 to 70 the
different groups some small that just
dedicate themselves to a single little
town somewhere there are armed groups
that are basically in control of that
area to some bigger federations like the
Sinaloa cartel which is probably
currently the largest and most powerful
one in Mexico
and the new generation cartel which is
growing exponentially right now
so these criminal groups are are players
in that conflict
then
another player that doesn't get talked
about is politics politicians
uh there's a there's an ongoing
discussion that has been going on I
think since Trump was elected about uh
cartels being a terrorist organist
cartels being terrorist organizations or
not or if they fit that description
well um you know we are living through
uh multiple assassinations on political
candidates out in Mexico right now and
most of those assassinations are
motivated by one side sponsoring one
candidate and the other side sponsoring
the other what I mean by sides I mean
cartel groups so they're they have
elected officials that are on the take
and this is we have you know many
Governors who are under investigation on
the run or in prison right now
uh State Governors so politics is
involved in it that's a big player as
well that doesn't you know when you when
you think about the cartel problems you
don't think well some at least some most
people don't think about that aspect of
it so to have integrity as a politician
in Mexico means
you have no protection and under
constant threat of assassination we just
seen the arrest and prosecution of the
head of all counter cartel operations
when I was active uh in the form of
Garcia Luna who was the he was he was
the guy Philippe Calderon who kicked off
the drug war that was his guy turns out
he was turns out he was on the deck at a
level is there like a spectrum of how on
the take you can be are there ethical
lines that you can cross some of it is
money and then
is it possible to operate in a gray area
that does not
result in destructive ethical violations
deep ethical violations I have no idea I
don't think I don't think there is
realistically I mean anything that kind
of uh supports some of these groups you
know you're supporting things of a
horrible nature
uh they're I just posted recently on my
Instagram account of a lady that was in
Guanajuato
she's one of seven recently assassinated
women that are looking for their kids
basically
uh there's a bunch of uh groups and
organizations out there in Mexico and
some in Tijuana that I've actually
walked with
who are
taking control of trying to find the
bodies of their kids
that's her up there Maria Carmela
Vasquez a mother who searched for a
missing son was shot to death outside
her home
on Sunday her son Osmar Vasquez
disappeared on June 14th the 46 year old
woman is the fifth mother to be killed
this year while searching for their
missing loved ones she was a member of
the Panama missing person Collective
there's many groups out in Mexico who
basically have given up on trusting the
government to find their kids
um the number of missing in Mexico is uh
debated topic uh because you know the
government itself doesn't release uh
those numbers uh or at least hasn't uh
done a good job about keeping them and
or releasing them
um Mexico is a country that has
industrialized Body Disposal you know uh
and Tijuana we had these two maker the
legendary stew maker which is a guy that
basically
use Caustic Acid acid uh to get rid of
bodies at a massive level so there's a
separate operation for getting rid of
bodies and murdering at least at least
in Tijuana we saw that phenomenon and I
I it's it's obvious that it's it's going
on all over Mexico who's having those
discussions about
mass murder and getting rid of people
I've been reading a lot about World War
II recently and there's was aggressive
Innovation on the Nazi side of how to
get rid of a large number of people
because For the Longest Time both the
Soviets and the Soviets were more brutal
with this it's literally it's a
engineering problem of how you kill a
large number of people and get rid of
their bodies so the Soviets were more
into
uh just laying people laying people down
into the grave face down and then
shooting them in the back of the head
and then doing that in that scale so you
just pile people on and then there's
obviously Innovation with the Holocaust
in terms of gassing people and all that
kind of stuff I'm not sure exactly where
these
trade craft skills are coming from
specifically
um you hear discussions of Israelis
training some of the cartel groups back
in the late 90s uh specifically the
Ariana fuse cartel there's a lot of
stories about that a security specialist
coming down and showing them things like
how to make caustic soda
um how to put rocks inside of bodies and
then chicken wire them around and throw
them into the ocean or or Rivers so that
their bodies don't float
and when you kind of put rocks inside of
body to make sure the body doesn't float
so you uh you open up the intestinal
tract put rocks inside
uh you cut where tattoos are you take
off hands and faces and throw them
somewhere else and you wrap them in
chicken wire so make it not identifiable
yeah and throw them into a body of water
and this is
this is this is a horrible thing but
it's actually the craft it's a tree
craft it's a trait it's it's tradecraft
and it's uh it there's a there's a link
to the EOS as far as having that trade
graph you have to remember that uh the
United States had a thing called School
of the Americas and and the CIA and they
showed things and a lot of that uh stuff
is out there in the hands of people that
are of that generation
so yeah there's a manual there's a
manual sign uh like with chapters and
it's like how to get rid of the body
there's manuals out there under time
constraints or what what are how
identifiable can the body be afterwards
what what a geographical constraints all
that kind of stuff I think I think that
was common back in the early 2000s uh
and maybe the late 90s when some of
these things were going on
but they've lost even that as far as
respect for the government or bodies
being found right now you what you
usually see is just bodies being burnt
to a crisp and buried in the field
somewhere that's usually what you'll see
uh some of the groups like this uh this
woman uh this woman belonged to
basically taken upon themselves to go
out to find uh clandestine Graves uh in
the outskirts of of the towns that
they're that they live in
um probing the ground with uh these
metal probes
and seeing if the uh the whatever they
encounter in the bottom of these uh
these clandestine Graves stinks or not
uh if they find IDs or clothing they
kind of gather that and they basically
present it to the investigative
authorities in the towns or the states
they live in which basically are doing
their jobs
you know over 90 percent of all murders
in Mexico were never solved uh I mean
it's uh so they they've even stopped
trying to get rid of bodies in that way
you know